welcome to this video the other sister
kickoff to another new series and this
series will be about about opening
disasters opening misstep violation of
opening principles those short games
that sometimes happen if one side is
really making mistakes yeah neglecting
their the king neglecting their
development those kind of things and
this will also feature some some opening
ideas for sure but mostly show how how
not to do it so I'm going to kick off
with a game of of mine that I'm going to
show it's there are some somewhat hazy
details about this game I of course know
that I played a grandmaster poem on
Ronnie and I was black in this game and
it was in the Dutch league but I have I
have lost them the the score sheet of
the game so I'm not 100% sure when this
was played
it must be an must have been in the
early 2000s 2002 2003 around this time
but this has not found the way into a
big database somehow surprisingly it was
the first Dutch league so pretty decent
level event and yeah I lost the score
sheet maybe I also destroyed it after
the game I really don't know but yeah
let's see what what happened in this
game
I was blackened but Ronnie played one
see for ya mod money was for quite a
long time the top Scottish Grandmaster
always rated around 2500 in a way at the
time I think he was a little bit lower
and I'm not sure that he's that active
anymore he also wrote chess books quite
nice once
okay so let's see what happened here got
c4 c5 the symmetrical English Knight f3
g6 Knight c3 Bishop g7 the move order of
that mites might have been slightly
different like it maybe have played the
night first of course I know that the
big point of the of the whole thing but
not the 100% sure move order yeah I know
that here he definitely in this position
he definitely played the move III which
of course surprised me it's not a very
common way to play this to play this
opening but with white white normally he
has to the two main plans he can just
start the the kingside fianchetto after
this here black has this huge selection
he can play e5 e6 d6 Knight f6 all kinds
of stuff all white can play D form this
is the other main approach however in
this position it's good to know that
it's not a super correct move it's it's
a little bit a little bit iffy because
here white is not able to to hold to d4
he needs to move the knight again
definitely does not want to take on c6
strength and blacks pawn Center so
Knight c2 is played and here black can
can and should take the chance to take
this check which really kills White's
pawn structure and it's normally
believed to be very good for black um
very good it's a bit is a bit much but
why this is struggling a bit here to
keep an equal game it's a very promising
for back so this is however played very
often yeah he played III it's not a bad
move I mean it's just a little bit a
little bit uncommon yeah here it's
interesting to note that Knight f6 and
knight c6 are two different things
entirely if I go knight c6 which is is
playable of course
then deform is a little bit problematic
for black
yeah d45 is is an annoying move if you
now play the capture you're not ready to
play d5 and white will probably push d5
with the tempo on the night this is my
96 while being playable it's not super
comfortable I'm black and also by the
way go here but again after d5 he faces
a temple loss with the night yeah I
played 96 I think this is just better
because after d4 now you don't need to
worry about D 45 that much yeah here the
easiest way to place to capture and play
d5 I didn't want to do that at the time
because I had very limited knowledge of
of this type of thing which is basically
a transposition to a Carroll camp on off
and I remember that I also didn't want
to do that because mod Vani is at the
time at least was a very versatile
player and his openings he played efore
d4c for all moves so I thought that he
probably has more experience in this
open type of position the span of
caro-kann type of position than I have
so after this d4
I went castles first my rationale was
that they're only really decent move
that White has in my thinking was Bishop
e2 that Ike that I expected and then I
would have taken and go D 5 and now if
he then takes he has the bishop on e 2
instead of on C 4 which would have been
more active yeah I like to show it once
again in comparison here white may go
Bishop c4 which is more active than
bishop on e2 so I wanted to wait a move
and let him commit to e2 before I get to
get on with the taking however after
some consideration the dasai remember I
didn't play this quickly he took on c5
and this caught me by surprise I had
never seen this this move I mean this is
a backwater of chess theory anyway so
it's not like
people invest hours to study this
position but he takes e5 I definitely
didn't really expect yeah it takes it
takes away from the center D take C and
if I get the pawn back well I should be
in good shape
yeah Black has a ton of alternatives
here the easiest looking is in a way
Queen a5 yeah and just setting up this
and lining up to take the pawn back
that's okay
definitely but I thought well why not
Knight a six yeah I'm in developing this
piece and I get to take on c5 with the
night where it is nicely placed yeah I
what I expected is was a move like we
should be too let's say no I'm looking
then I take here castles and now black
can yeah or should decide between d6
b6 something like that maybe b6 and I'm
going Bishop b7 possibly 94 I was really
delighted yeah thought okay this is nice
why not this is a nice position white is
not very active and I was a little bit
asking myself what has big ideas with
this with this whole whole set up
because it looks very unambitious
however he had an ambitious idea he now
played the move III e4 which looks a bit
weird because it in a way loses a movie
on a first a3 and then he form but yeah
it has a concrete very concrete at the
end yeah he's maybe planning to play e5
and I really don't have any other
sensible move I believe and maybe things
like win a five but 95 is my father the
most the most obvious move IAM taking
the pawn back and directly attacking
here if we now do a base the tempo count
yeah we see that black has three pieces
in play now the Knights and the bishop
and he has Castle so black can really
spend very little time on other things
like developing yeah
he moved the c-pawn to stake a claim in
the center this has exchanged two with
the D pawn and what why did he played
the capture out of the sent and is free
for so white in a way has violated some
opening principles he now played the
movie v again leaving this poem again
yeah it's the third move of the pawn and
yeah I I started to invest some time
thinking what to do I was really not
believing White's play that much I
thought I should have an okay position
at least and when I was considering
Knight takes e5 the move earlier I had
already looked at e5 of course I was
expecting the move as it is the only one
that they had really threatens black in
a way if if or hangs him and if he does
not play e5 let's say he plays this to
cover the pawn otherwise I'll just take
it and after that I just go d6 and this
is a type of maroc C bind where black
has basically yeah he's one moves like
e3 e4 the bishop is not particularly
great here on on d3 you have possibly
this Bishop move coming with the pin so
that's a very comfortable position now
at least compared to a normal Roxy
blankets in really excellent shape
so if I've must be the critical move in
a way to move that tests like and what I
was considering as mentioned beforehand
that he would play that and after some
considerations
I played the move Knight e4 here Knight
F takes e4 and what I calculated was was
pretty clear I thought that okay what
mistake
everything else does not make much sense
I mean moving the Queen Queen c2 those
kind of moves again neglecting
development he mistake this makes the
most sense and I was thinking okay well
the night only four is a little bit of a
lone warrior here it's a little bit on
its own and what
I what I mostly calculated here was the
move Queen to deform yeah attacking
attacking in this night but I was
thinking okay I can share Queen a5 and
then what can you do it should be - well
I just take and well something something
like this is excellent
yeah d6 takes rook the 8th and Black is
in a fantastic shape he has two bishops
in an open position
the king is is running around and this
is this is awful yeah and well Queen a5
check if he moves the King at least
needs to be considered
it's it looks totally off like this I
can just move the knight again I was
really calculating this stuff Bishop d2
Queen c7 and and black is fine the king
is is bad on d1 and yeah I was also
thinking okay if he if he attacks it
like that again I have this this check
which forces him to move the King or
lead to something like that this is a
bit better than Jack then then Queen d4
in comparison
yeah like d6 takes and again I have this
great Bishop and any good game yeah and
while I was waiting for him to play the
move and I was calculating I was
suddenly made her he made his move and
he played Queen d5 and it hit me pretty
pretty quickly that this nice straight
yeah this was one of the more
embarrassing moments of of my my active
just just playing just playing Korea
he was just attacking this night and it
has nowhere to go and the most the most
weird thing is that I I really saw that
the night is a little bit on its own and
there so Queen d4 I really invest the
time to check that Queen deform was not
working and I really thought that was an
excellent shape here because Queen a5
was a threat and everything and then he
played Queen d5 and this has the really
awkward yeah true
function this move of course that it
takes the night the main thing but it
takes away c5 so I cannot go in there I
cannot pay queen a5 check as he just
covers the square and that also cannot
play f5 as the F pawn is pinned this
always was something let's say Queen D
for if there was something wrong with
Queen 85 at least ahead f5
yeah even this is pretty good for black
so I was really thinking about who the
Queen moving in the center but I thought
some reason for some reason I only saw
Queen d4 but not 25 yeah and after Queen
if I was really really shocked yeah it
also was an important game so it was not
like something that I mean you you just
laugh about and and and go on it was
really really awful and yeah I didn't
resign immediately by the way I was sir
I was still trying something I played I
think I cannot really recall it
completely I think I played d6 Queen
takes and something like this trying to
to irritate him something like this nd 4
but why just played 2 or 3 more moves
and then I resigned I was simply in a
way too shocked to to immediately resign
yeah pretty pretty awful experience and
it shows that those kind of if you have
a single piece that's on its own in a
way disconnected from your faucets it's
always very very very problematic and I
probably should have triple checked if
there is something then maybe I will
spot it Queen d5 yeah if we briefly go
back this is not the main point of it
but if we briefly go back as I said and
I think correctly White has violated
some opening principles here by moving
the e pawn again and again and again
it's a bit weird shouldn't like be able
to exploit this in fact I never really
looked at this afterwards
simply because I thought well I'm an
idiot I just blundered this piece and I
didn't really look at the game much
afterwards I only recorded when I was
thinking of starting this series that it
would be a nice way to kick it off and I
actually entered this into the comp and
it gives Knight g4 here in a way the
only other sensible moves you don't
really want to go back I mean going back
to e8 cannot be any any sort of
refutation of this and it turns out that
Knight g4 is really a really excellent
for black so much to my surprise our
firm when I saw it in then as a sort of
care maybe this is okay but it's not
okay black is much much better really
surprisingly I think how much better
blog is and black it's just attacking e5
twice and it's not so easy to do it's um
something about it
the move Queen t4 sort of in the spirit
of the other line is just terrible
because of d6 which covers the night and
sets up this pin so oops of course this
one yeah Queen d4 is really really bad
this cannot be considered even yeah what
should do I do actually Bishop f4
probably this makes sense and now black
has a very very strong move and I think
in the game actually my problem was that
I little bit violated the thus candidate
moves principle I was looking at 94 as
my initial choice and I liked it I
didn't see you obviously that that i
blundered and i thought i'm okay in our
lines let's play that and i didn't
really look at 94
yeah but in fact it is very good after
Bishop f4 maybe I also failed to see
what I should do after Bishop f4 this is
possible definitely I don't remember
exactly it is certainly more than 10
years ago
the point is white white is of course
I'm covering a5 and it is not so obvious
what black should do if if you play a
slow move yeah and it looks like these
six is not possible if you play a slow
move then white might just play h3
kick the knight back from g4 and all
didn't make much sense this is not not a
good move of course we can jump in here
and something like this while he just
dropped back and I haven't gained much
yeah the the very strong move here that
maybe this is what I what I missed
I'm not sure is d6 and it first it looks
like crazy why should this be possible
but it turns out to be very very strong
and the big point is that after the
capture which in a way looks like the
only sensible move otherwise I will just
take a 5 and I never ever lose 1 upon so
if he takes black now has Queen b6 and
this is maybe not so apparent at first
but give this to a computer black is
winning here already it is not just like
a good position black wins and yeah why
is that if if one takes only seven black
plays rook e8 threatening rookie 7 and
the problem is there is big pressure on
f2 and b2 if white is now playing
something like this
normal-looking move then I'm already
killing him that's very powerful King
takes 94 check animation mate now very
nice and it is absolutely impossible now
to defend if white plays Queen d2 which
is relatively speaking the best covering
F 2 and B 2 then black captures and
white cannot take it's not possible you
go look like there should be 2 and 93
yeah this is this is devastating look at
the f to pawn this is the main point
if white retreats check
check check check and white is
completely killed yeah it's not like you
can calculate this but you can
definitely see if you put this it's
tough to get that far once you see this
and you see the the combined threats
against F to be two it becomes apparent
that it is dangerous for white you
cannot really probably you cannot really
tell that black is winning the comp is
just very simply stating minus two but
that's it that's difficult for a human
player but you can definitely see it is
very dangerous
yeah well the best line relatively
speaking is Queen d2 he takes d6 and now
it gets where it gets very tough for
for--why to defend the combined threaten
see especially whoop e8 yeah something
like this is relatively speaking best
and this is yeah this is quite a
statement as for like can of course take
you know the big point is this is a
double check and in this concrete case
this is even stronger because we can't
make it in a direct mate or
alternatively checkmate this one so I
actually could have punished him very
severely for this before ii v iii-vi ii
v business this kind of slow advance of
the e pawn which lost lots of time but i
blundered instead of yeah almost
refuting the whole thing 94 was was much
stronger but yeah it's it's very useful
to remember that you really should
triple check once you come to a
situation where a piece is somewhat
disconnected from your from your
position red is unprotected and on its
own sometimes there are surprising ways
to trap such a piece even in the center
like here the knight on e4 yeah i
somehow failed to see Queen d5 I saw
Queen d4 I remember that
and it was this was this experience when
he shoved the queen of the ball and it
landed on d5 and not only for this was
shocking okay I hope you enjoyed this
probably more than then I did you can
have played the game thanks for watching